we have this incredible pairing magnus
cast negotia
in the very last run usually we would be
going crazy for this pairing but knowing
that all this craziness is happening
with the qualification
uh it's it's kind of
what
[Music]
he can't stop
both it's it's i have to say it's kind
of nice to see these two players having
a laugh like this we've seen them fight
it out and we've seen them uh who can
forget the magnus carlson chester final
we've seen some epic battles between the
two this one is just it's just a joke
well i mean can you imagine we have been
asking for a new draw yeah instead of
the berlin stuff and look at this the
berlin position had already happened
[Music]
to make sure that he he qualifies and we
see one draw there we see another draw
shakti a mama del vagan vastly so
reaching the same end game and now is
this the called bone claw yeah it was it
was something like of a bone claude
business this king he took his hair and
stuff i mean please definitely don't
like at home i mean guys just just
forget about it no i i know that setup
was mentioning that he really covered it
in his chesapeake course i mean okay
guys but no no just just don't do this